On the Bus.
Marissa and her mother were riding the bus.
They were on their way to Grandma's house.
They had to sit in the back seats.
Marissa didn't like the back seats.
There was a law that black people had to sit at the back of the bus.
Her mother said it was unfair.
Some white people came on the bus.
So some of the black people stood up and gave them their seats.
That was another part of the law.
Refusing to Stand.
But one black woman didn't stand up.
Her name was Rosa Parks.
She didn't want to move from her seat.
The driver told Rosa she had to move, but she said, "No."
Then the driver called the police!
The police came and arrested Rosa Parks.
Marissa was very confused.
Why didn't Rosa Parks get up?
Everybody knew the law, even if it wasn't fair.
Taking Steps.
When other people heard what happened to Rosa, they got very upset.
They decided to stop riding the city buses!
Marissa asked her mom why they had to walk.
Her mother said people stopped riding the buses to show that the law was unfair.
For a long time they walked everywhere.
Marissa's legs were sometimes very tired.
Still, they didn't ride the bus.
Making a Difference.
Finally, an amazing thing happened.
The law was changed!
Marissa and her mom could now sit at the front of the bus.
Marissa learned that one person could make a difference.
She learned people could join together to change things.
Today, people of all colors in the United States have the same rights.
It all started with one woman saying no to something that was unfair.